[Música]
tras una década en el poder el partido
islamista de marruecos fue derrotado en
las elecciones legislativas según los
resultados preliminares los partidos
liberales cercanos a la realeza se
alzaron con la victoria y ahora deberán
formar alianzas para conseguir una
mayoría absoluta
en parís se lleva a cabo la segunda
jornada del mayor juicio en la historia
gala contra los presuntos responsables
de los atentados de noviembre de 2015 en
francia en la audiencia de hoy el único
autor material vivo del ataque aseguró
que tres de los acusados no sabían nada
del plan tenemos información desde el
palacio de justicia
china anunció que donará 31 millones de
dólares afganistán entre alimentos y
vacunas contra el cob y 19 entretanto el
gobierno de qatar indicó que 200
extranjeros con documentación en regla
saldrán de kabul en las próximas horas
en el primer vuelo comercial desde la
retirada de las fuerzas estadounidenses
gracias por continuar con nosotros en
france 24 soy valentina torre sánchez y
es un gusto acompañarlos iniciamos esta
emisión de noticias en marruecos el
partido islamista que ha gobernado el
país desde la primavera árabe en 2011
sufrió una derrota histórica en las
elecciones generales y pasó de tener 125
escaños a 12 ahora los partidos
liberales los grandes vencedores tendrán
que buscar alianzas para formar gobierno
desde marrakech nuestra corresponsal
sofía catalán nos explica las causas que
generaron la caída de los islamistas el
partido islamista que ha gobernado
marruecos en los últimos 10 años se ha
desplomado en las elecciones
legislativas regionales y municipales
que se celebraron ayer el partido de la
justicia y el desarrollo como se llama
esta formación es el único partido
islamista legal aquí en marruecos y
ahora aparte de haber perdido el poder
en el parlamento también ha lo han
perdido a nivel regional y a nivel local
ya todos los analistas auguraban un
retroceso importante para la formación
pero al final resultó ser una caída sin
precedentes ahí quedaron en octavo lugar
y los motivos que explicarían a esta
gran caída son a la crisis interna que
sufre el partido pero sobre todo el gran
descontento popular ante la crisis
social y económica que atraviesa el país
y también la nueva ley electoral que
favorece a los partidos minoritarios y
el gran vencedor de las elecciones fue
el reagrupamiento nacional de
independientes una formación liberal
integrada por empresarios y altos cargos
de la administración y liderada por el
actual ministro de agricultura allí
shacknews quienes además el empresario
más adinerado del país durante la noche
el ministerio facilitó nuevos datos que
llego al 50 por ciento un poco mayor que
en 2016 aún así no deja de ser baja pues
existe un contexto de desinterés por la
política
institucional y por otra parte diversos
partidos mayoritarios entre ellos los
islamistas denunciaron irregularidades
en la campaña y acusan al partido
ganador de haber comprado los votos en
francia se instaló la segunda jornada
del macrojuicio contra los presuntos
responsables de los atentados
terroristas que golpearon al país en
noviembre de 2015 el proceso se lleva a
cabo en medio de estrictas medidas de
seguridad ayer las declaraciones de sala
abdeslam el único comando vivo
aumentaron la atención en la corte para
ampliar esta información conectamos con
nuestra periodista erika olavarría que
se encuentra a las afueras del palacio
de justicia eric a que ecos quedaron de
las declaraciones del principal acusado
hasta la abdeslam ayer durante el inicio
del juicio y que ha dicho hoy
valentina buenas tardes salac abdeslam
parece decidido a hablar llevamos un
poco más de una hora de audiencia y ya
tuvo que ser suspendida por los dichos
del único sobreviviente de los comandos
del 13 de noviembre que toma la palabra
sin la autorización del presidente de la
corte ayer recordemos lo hizo varias
veces en una de ellas se reconoció como
un combatiente del grupo de estado
islámico lo que afectó sobre todo a las
víctimas civiles presentes les propongo
que escuchemos algunos algunas víctimas
del ataque
ya no fue una reacción de sorpresa es
exactamente lo que él hizo en bruselas
lo que es un poco inesperado es que en
lugar de ceñirse a su lógica y dejar de
hablar respondió la mitad de las
preguntas sobre su dirección etcétera
creemos que hay poca inteligencia detrás
de su comportamiento
esta persona que está en el banquillo y
del que no diré ni el nombre ni el
apellido porque no quiero convertirlo en
el protagonista de esta historia para mí
y para mi asociación es un asesino
así que es una provocación lo
esperábamos y estábamos preparados para
ello y de hecho no esperamos nada de él
erika que se espera para hoy se retomará
la audiencia en qué momento que nuevos
detalles hay
la audiencia ya ha sido retomada
valentina había una discusión muy
técnica entre el presidente y los
abogados cuando salas de slam tomó la
palabra él dijo que en molenbeek su
barrio de bruselas conocido por el
salvajismo de los jóvenes había muchas
víctimas también preguntó cuándo se le
va a dar la voz a las víctimas de siria
y luego hizo una frase muy técnica dijo
la sabiduría creer que a un hombre se ha
condenado luego de ser juzgado nosotros
tenemos la presunción de inocencia
aunque no creamos en vuestra justicia
sino hoy continúa la lista no cierto de
las partes civiles es algo muy lento son
más de 1800 partes civiles esa tarea va
a durar hasta mañana vamos a ver si
nuevamente sala adelante toma la palabra
erika muchas gracias por toda esta
información estamos pendientes de lo que
ocurra en las próximas horas y seguimos
con nuestra serie de reportajes sobre
las víctimas de los atentados en francia
georges salín cuya hija murió en el
ataque de el bataclán le dedica gran
parte de su tiempo al trabajo de
prevención para evitar la radicalización
de jóvenes nuestra periodista claire
para clown se reunió con este médico
jubila en un parque de parís que le
recuerda a su hija lola
aquí está lo la arriba de la torre de
sant ya que eso creo yo la amaba parís
ella pasó su adolescencia y su juventud
aquí de verdad amaba esta ciudad
lola la hija de georges salinas fue
asesinada cuando tres hombres armados
entraron en la sala de conciertos
bataclán el 13 de noviembre del 2015
tenía 28 años y le gustaba andar en
patines la música y hacer amigos
el celular ex amamos aquí está lo la
junto a su mamá
90 víctimas fueron asesinadas en el
bataclán los tres atacantes también
murieron en el asalto
el padre de sam ya me murió uno de los
terroristas pidió conocer a george
sus conversaciones dieron origen a un
libro conjunto que incluye las cartas
que george escribió al atacante de 28
años
para mí
porque esta pregunta me da vueltas desde
el 13 de noviembre porque tú y tus
cómplices cometieron estos horribles
crímenes
y
probaste la vida a jóvenes de tu edad a
gente que ni siquiera conocías perdiste
tú mismo la vida en hacerlo sumergida de
los padres y amigos de los que mataste y
a tus propios padres y amigos en una
pesadilla usa bien ese depresión sentir
dejaste a los que sobrevivieron a tus
balas con heridas permanentes manchester
tu religión a los ojos del mundo pusiste
en peligro a todos los musulmanes
algunos de los cuales han pagado con su
vida en espantosos actos de venganza
indiscriminada todo eso con qué
propósito
este mes de septiembre se abre el
proceso de los acusados envueltos en
estos ataques george ha decidido hablar
frente a la corte
lula y
lola es una de las víctimas de los
atentados del 13 de noviembre y no deseo
que esté ausente del juicio de esos
asesinos
maestros psicólogos y trabajadores
penitenciarios a menudo piden a georges
que dé charlas sobre lola
él lleva fotos de su hija describe su
personalidad y explica lo que le pasó un
trabajo que busca prevenir la
radicalización
en otras noticias el gobierno chino
anunció que donará 31 millones de
dólares en cereales y vacunas contra el
coi 19 afganistán al tiempo que pidió a
los talibanes que rompan todos los lazos
que mantengan con grupos extremistas
entretanto el gobierno de qatar informó
que 200 extranjeros saldrán del país en
el primer vuelo comercial que despegará
de kabul desde la retirada de las
fuerzas estadounidenses por su parte los
talibanes exigieron que se excluya a sus
líderes de las listas negras de naciones
unidas y estados unidos mientras que
condenaron los comentarios hechos contra
los integrantes del ejecutivo interino
el nuevo régimen talibán anunció que va
a recuperar el llamado ministerio de
propagación de la virtud y prevención
del vicio es una especie de ministerio
de la moralidad que durante su primer
gobierno se conoció por las duras
sanciones contra las mujeres y cualquier
persona que contraviniera el orden
talibán para analizar este tema
conectamos con el imán marwan el
presidente de la comunidad musulmana
ahmadía en argentina gracias por
acompañarnos hay una sola manera de
entender la moralidad o las normas del
islam
no es una una pregunta muy interesante
porque hoy en día en el islam no existe
una sola rama o una interpretación del
islam en realidad hoy en día en el islam
tenemos más de 70 corrientes ramas
diferentes facciones
entonces tenemos diferentes formas de
interpretar y aplicar la sharía que es
el camino religioso o la ley islámica en
este asunto la interpretación de los
talibanes es una interpretación muy
rigurosa muy polémica y que incluso la
mayoría de los musulmanes lo rechazan y
no están de acuerdo con tal
interpretación en el caso de la
comunidad musulmana amarilla nosotros
condenamos principalmente su
interpretación y su aplicación de la
sharía de la ley islámica incluso muchos
de sus asuntos y su interpretación de la
sharía contradice a los propios
principios y mandamientos y leyes de la
sharía no en procurar ejemplo el caso de
la mujer la sharía otorga a la mujer el
derecho de obtener educación desde la
tumba desde la cuna hasta la tumba y por
ejemplo los talibanes no interpretan la
sharía en una forma totalmente opuesto a
la propia sharía imán usted justamente
lo estaba mencionando pero le pregunto
qué riesgos que otros riesgos conlleva a
este ministerio para la población afgana
y sobre todo para las mujeres y para las
niñas
es muy preocupante y realmente doloroso
porque ellos en realidad ocultan
esconden su propia ideología
su propia agenda no es importante
aclarar que los talibanes es un
movimiento principalmente que surgió en
un contexto como un movimiento militar
con una agenda geopolítica y ellos
tienen su propia ideología de sus
propias tradiciones normas culturales
pero lo más preocupante y triste para el
mundo musulmán es que ellos ocultan a su
ideología con la tapa del islam y en ese
son todavía mente es el gran peligro que
ellos ahora conformen su propia
interpretación del islam o de la sharía
van a usurpar los derechos de cualquier
persona que se opone a su ideología y
obviamente ahí la el grupo más
vulnerable son los grupos religiosos o
las minorías religiosas y obviamente
también la mujer y van a imponer a la
mujer su propia ideología en nombre del
islam y obviamente eso es como muy
preocupante muy alarmante para el mundo
musulmán y también una gran mancha para
la imagen del islam
usted también menciona esto de algo pero
quiero que lo amplíe por favor realmente
el islám ordena los castigos y las
restricciones a las libertades que están
imponiendo los talibanes con la
interpretación varía según esta cultura
y el lugar no así no incluso analiza los
diferentes puntos que han anunciado los
talibanes sobre su interpretación de la
ley de la ley islámica y de la sharía si
lo comparamos directamente con la sharía
encontramos realmente una gran
contradicción y es una diferencia entre
día y noche y solamente para hablar por
ejemplo el velo la burka la sharía el
propio corán anuncia que no hay coacción
en la fe es decir que nadie en ninguna
institución sea religiosa o política
tiene el derecho de imponer algo en
nombre de dios porque el corán anuncia
no hay coacción en la fe en la religión
después como ya dije el islam ya en el
107 otorgó a la mujer el derecho de
obtener educación de votar de ser una
parte productiva y activa de la sociedad
de heredad propiedad de manejar
libremente dinero de casarse por su
propia conexión incluso el derecho de
divorcio entonces hay una larga lista de
derechos que la mujer ya recibió y 27 y
los talibanes lamentablemente
interpretan el islam conforme sus
propios intereses y ocultan y eso es lo
más triste que usan la tapa del islam
para realizar su ideología y para
imponer su ideología y obviamente es una
dictadura cuyas herramientas principales
es la violencia es
usurpar los derechos y oprimir las voces
de las minorías en este caso de las
mujeres
desde su percepción el gobierno talibán
y sus acciones podrían provocar una
especie de estigmatización de la
comunidad musulmana a nivel mundial sí
creo que ya lo ocurrió no si nosotros
analizamos porque no es la primera vez
que los talibanes gobiernan el país ya
lo hicieron desde los años 1996 y 2001 y
si uno analiza la situación de los
musulmanes en occidente la islamofobia
la generalización de los estereotipos
los prejuicios
aumentó en las últimas dos décadas si
hay más choques hay más confrontaciones
al contexto lo que ocurre en afganistán
o con los talibanes con al qaeda
obviamente ellos fomentan y ellos
activamente manchan la imagen del islam
y fomentan los prejuicios contra los
musulmanes pero acá me gustaría aclarar
que ellos no representan las enseñanzas
verdaderas del islam ni siquiera es una
parte importante adentro del mundo
musulmán tenemos alrededor de un casi
2.000 millones musulmanes en el mundo y
la gran mayoría la mayoría de las
escuelas teológicas
rechazan el talibán y su forma de
interpretar el islam y me gusta
muchísimas gracias por este análisis y
por esta ampliación a ustedes gracias
por su sintonía recuerden que pueden
ampliar todas las noticias en nuestra
web france24 puntocom
[Música]